في المقابل قالت قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه تستعد لشن
هجوم صاروخي على اوكرانيا من البحر الاسود
واضافتنا الفرقه ادمرال ماكارون فتوجهت
الى البحر الاسود وعلى متنها ثمانيه
صواريخ وطلبت قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه سكان المنطقه بعدم تجاهل
انذارات الجويه
وبتوخي الحذر
وفي مقاطعه خرسون جنوبا افاد مراسل
الجزيره عن تصاعد حده القصف المتبادل بين
ضفتين نهر دنيبر وقال المتحدث باسم
الاداره العسكريه في منطقه اوديسا
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تستهدفت مواقع
للقوات الروسيه في قريه فيليكي كوباني على
الضفه اليسرى من منطقه خرسون ما ادى لمقتل
العشرات من القوات الروسيه هذا ياتي في
مشاهد مدينه وضواحيها قصفا صاروخيا ليليا
عقب دوي صفارات الانذار
اعلنت سلطات ودونياسك المواليه لروسيا في
شرق اوكرانيا مقتله مدني واصابه اخر في
قصف اوكراني على مدينه ياسينوفاتشيا وقالت
ان الجيش الاوكراني قصف خلال الساعات
الماضيه 5 مناطق سكنيه بنحو 70 قذيفه
وصاروخا من عيارات مختلفه مضيفه ان القصف
ادى الى تدمير سته منازل سكنيه ومنشاه
للبنيه التحتيه المدنيه